We decided to install SportsVU cameras because
they gave really enhanced data but they were
being installed individually by certain select
teams.
And we thought that it should be available
to the league as a whole.
Those teams weren’t that happy about it
but the tradeoff was they now got the data
as all teams did from 29 arenas rather than
from just the few that had it.
And that has worked out very well for us.
If you want to have four trillion facts you
can go to NBA.com/stats and the SAP HANA program
will give you all of those statistics.
You’ve got the SportsVU statistics.
You’ve got a high speed arena network that
brings the video back from every arena for
replay.
But once it’s there for replay it can be
diced and chopped and sent out, Tweeted, you
name it.
So we’re, you know, the age of analytics
is upon us and we wanted to be ahead of it.
And that’s like an example of things being
available to us that weren’t available before.
Pre SportsVU – a decade ago we were primitive
compared to where we are now and I think in
another decade we’ll look back and see how
primitive we are now but we’re so much further
advanced because I’ve been wearing my venture
capital hat.
I’ve been looking at some applications in
sports.
It’s amazing and it’s like not amazing.
You know and you can stop the camera and look.
At this moment that player in that position
if he shoots he’s a 60 percent shooter.
If he moves three feet to his right or his
left or down court he becomes a 40 percent
shooter.
You know the ability to know so much about
your team and every other team and about every
player current and future is very much going
to make big data a much more relevant player
in all sports and including the NBA.
It’s currently at the stage where every
team has two or three or four or five or six
people dealing with data.
In some cases in the last couple of years
they didn’t know what to do with it.
And in many cases the coaches will say well
it’s, you know, it’s good to have but
you’ve got to have your instincts as well.
I think ultimately it’s going to affect
the substitutional patterns.
There’s going to be a coach, assistant coach
on the bench that’s going to be looking
at the video of the game, everything else.
And you’re going to know exactly – at
the end of the game your opposing team is
going to go to this player 82 percent of the
time for that shot, let’s defend him.
And in some ways the coach has to understand
and will and they do understand because they’re
smart and they’re adaptive.
It’s one thing to say player X shoots 50
percent but if he shoots 60 percent from the
left and 40 percent from the right you better
get him the ball on the left.
And you don’t know that unless you use the
data to tell you that.